Can I come with you today? It's my
childhood friend Misuzu. Let's get along
well.
[Music]
You're Junichiro. You're
from Tokyo. That's
right, but you have a rustic face. He's a
funny guy, and he picks fights with everyone.  It's not
fun.
[Music] It's my
first time being alone. What kind of insects can I catch? I can
catch stag beetles and beetles, seriously.
But I don't want to go to weird places anymore. I'll climb up the
cliff, the river will stand, it's
okay. I'm going to
climb these stairs today.  I'll take a photo somewhere. It's
only about 200 steps. Are
you a monster? Look, you're an enthusiastic kid. I'm the best. That's amazing.
Muzan. In the end, the one who's still standing wins in the end. You [Music]
and I are really good friends.  Hey